we're here in Twilight so let's do this
[Music]
one of the good things about Europe of
course there are many good things about
Europe
but especially
the gelato I wanted more gelato that
could fit on an ice cream cone so I got
it in a cup then I just got the cone
separate and just stick that on there
and then I eat that last that way it
doesn't fall off when I'm eating it
nothing scientific about that it's just
simple facts this is pistachio
and chocolate
make a nice combo
you want some yeah
our whole production team is in London
for a few days and we're doing a Star
Talk presentation at a conference on
Space sustainability that's a thing
because we're crowding space low earth
orbit space with countless satellites
you've read about them these
constellations of satellites in fact I'm
angry they call them constellations
because constellations of stars that's
stuff that should be up there and we
look at them and they're beautiful they
have names they have history to put
satellites up there and call it a
constellation that ain't right maybe we
should call them a train
of satellites that's what it is yeah so
how sustainable is that in the future
who knows because space is getting very
crowded but anyhow that's why we're all
here but right now we're just driving
around joyriding enjoy riding around the
city London we'll just stop wherever
I feel like I have something sciency to
say some I might be scraping bottom to
get the science out of it but I mean why
not we'll go wherever science takes us
and at the end of the day there's
science in everything
by the way have you ever made ice cream
with liquid nitrogen you never have
put it on your list
[Music]
so I'm here in London and that's
Parliament behind me and of course the
big clock at the top there Big Ben
I think Big Ben is specifically the Bell
not the clock itself last I knew I think
we tried to make a big Bell and then it
cracked
the Liberty Bell so I don't know if that
was a sign that maybe our Liberty is
broken
oh oh hey what are the odds let's
calculate that there's eight billion
people in the world too many yeah no
they'll go to 10 billion and it'll
settle off there did you know that no
yeah they'll settle it about 10 billion
okay and of all the places one could be
this is a pretty highly traveled Place
yeah thousands of people within so 8
billion out of a thousand that's a
million the chances of one in eight
million if at the beginning of today you
said what are my chances of meeting
Neil deGrasse Tyson
however if you ask yourself what are my
chances of meeting someone who I
recognize
no matter who it is it's way higher than
that
way higher I guess yeah it's way higher
it's way higher if you take a look down
at the at the the bridge support notice
its shape Leonardo da Vinci wrote
extensively about what shape Bridge
support should have that are in the
water so how they would park the
currents otherwise the current would
like chew on the base of the bridge and
ultimately destroy it so just so you
know they're Engineers civil engineers
thinking about this stuff so that you
don't have to Leonardo was a engineer a
military Machinery expert and he did
physics oh and he was also an artist
Leonardo anyhow uh here we are reporting
from London
on the summer solstice
June 21st okay okay everybody's in we're
gonna selfie there everybody so you guys
are in from where where are you guys in
from California what part
okay
uh well for my podcast start talk oh
yeah yeah that's so cool it start talk
visits London oh it's cool no stay with
it stay with it take hard classes
you'll be better off even if your grade
drops a little bit the hard class will
matter more than the difference in the
grade okay
you got it okay now you
know
that's what I thought she had in mind at
the beginning
they totally bogarted their way in okay
guys thanks for your interest okay guys
actually a friend of mine made you in
Australia and I was so jealous now you
have now you can go back at him
well he was wearing a NASA shirt if you
wear a NASA bling then you in the club
that's just how that works
yeah that's just this is like what's it
called virtue signaling that the cosmos
is your thing and so
so that's what they were they were from
Bulgaria the folks before that were from
Australia
then Oklahoma
but just one seeing tourists on this
bridge while we were trying to film star
talk and the people who just have their
own enthusiasm for Science and I'm I'm
honored that I can play a role in
feeding that enthusiasm and so
there it is
back to the van but we can all fit in
one of those
cool
[Music]
so we're here at Buckingham Palace first
time I've ever stood here seen pictures
of it with the queen waving to people
and we all learned how to wave from the
queen this is the only Queen I've ever
known my entire life I mean Elizabeth II
by the way Queen Elizabeth the First
overlapped with Galileo except Galileo
was Italian but I thought I'd put this
in historical context for you here's
something interesting I think in the
1700s early 1800s England was our sworn
enemy they came and burned the White
House or swarm enemy and now they are
our closest Ally in the world maybe
after Canada but on some level it's the
same difference what does it take to go
from Arch Enemy to closest Ally does a
war have to be fought
to be an ally Lincoln is known for
saying best way to defeat your enemy is
to Simply make them your friends
from Iraq okay yeah great pleasure
excellent okay thank you thank you thank
you
my name is prakash I'm from Dubai Dubai
okay so Dubai has the bird Khalifa right
yeah okay cool you know I like about it
the sun sets three minutes later at the
top so don't they make a sheet so that
you know when Ramadan fasting ends
because it's different it's different at
the top at the bottom yeah very cool
full Garden Star Talk this is badass
this is badass you hear what I said
that's a badass well London of course
we're using our Out of This World
Luggage The Limited collab with solgar
and star talk this collab includes the
Moon Mars and NASA suitcase and inside
the carry-on closet the patented magical
closet system that allows you to stay
organized on the go Soul guard makes
travel easier and it's sustainably made
too every item saves five pounds of
plastic from entering our ocean the
luggage is back in stock while supplies
last visit soulguard.com StarTalk to
learn more
[Music]
so the first time I came to London I was
14 years old I was by myself it was the
beginning of a multi-week stay where I
studied part of an expedition
archaeologists and other scientists to
study
monuments in the British Isles up into
Scotland that resemble Stonehenge but
are not as famous as Stonehenge or not
as well preserved so they're these
Stones throughout right the folks back
then they erected some Stones all right
you look at Stonehenge and you think
it's singular it's not one of very many
examples and some of them were Uncharted
so we had a map of those that were
Uncharted and the t i and 12 other
people I brought through the
astronomical knowledge to the table
other people brought archaeological
knowledge because I've been doing
astronomy like since I was a little kid
so so we found these stones and they're
typically in Farmers Fields so we just
checked we first document them because
the farmers didn't like the stones
because it disrupts their farming
practice so we fully document them
photographed them and then mapped where
they were with respect to each other and
to the sky
into any rising and setting points of
the sun moon and stars so that's what I
did and by the way that was kind of a
Stonehenge baptism for me we did visit
Stonehenge in the Salisbury Plain it's
because of that trip
that I said to myself I got to bring
some of this back to New York City some
years later I would be in Central Park
surrounded by Lawns and trees and Beyond
the trees are the rooftops of tall
buildings and I thought I wonder if
there's a place to stand where there's
fun alignments with the sun moon and
stars and I couldn't find one so I just
went I settled for something that I knew
I'd be able to identify but I was hoping
to get more and so I said let me just
publish the dates where the sun sets
exactly on the geometric grid of the
Manhattan streets
and so then I call that Manhattan hinge
and so now you know when I first
published the photos back in 2002
no one really knew about it or cared
about it I'm delighted to report that
tens of thousands of people flood the
streets
during those two days a year where the
sun sets right on the grid traffic gets
stopped finally for reasons other than
Con Ed [ __ ] holes and police activity
I would cherish any moment where someone
is blocking traffic because of some
Cosmic phenomena
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
we sleep never
[Music]
we're here in Twilight so let's do this
okay
oh
foreign
[Music]
the day after the solstice but the sun
will still rise in the same place as it
did yesterday so I'm not worried about
that and we've got a security guard
coming approaching us right now we might
be on private property but we'll find
out in a moment but anyhow Stonehenge is
there in front of us and we're now right
now aligned with the heel stone
and the heelstone is actually between
two vertical
columns and unfortunately we have trees
on the horizon so we're not going to get
a clean rise of the sun and the Sun is
going to rise at a very steep angle
so it'll be interesting to see where it
shows up when it finally manifests
itself from behind the trees and so we
might have to sort of shift a little
this way to get it at least over the
structure uh to at least capture some of
the spirit that the original
Architects had intended just a little
emotional for me because I haven't
been to Stonehenge since I was 14 years
old
this is like 50 years ago
and here it is again
back then we could like climb all over
the stones and of course
you knew over time that wouldn't end
well and so of course the Stonehenge
Monument is cordoned off we are here the
day after the solstice but the sun
rising angles would still be close
enough to what they were yesterday so
that it would make no important
difference when I came here I was with
the guy who first decoded it he wrote
the book decoding Stonehenge his name is
Gerald Hawkins because we came here just
to sort of Benchmark what we were about
to do in the rest of the British Isles
we went into Scotland and their other
Stone like I said none this well
preserved and none this large but
there's tons of them I don't know if you
noticed their sign there was woodhenge
and there's a they're Avery there's
another circle of stones that are not
this big they're more craggy chunks of
rock but there's a bunch of these
throughout the British Isles so whatever
was going on it was a common thing to do
so the fully constructed thing you'd
have the vertical stones and then the
cap stones and then this would complete
a circle and there's an inner circle to
that as well right that's why busier
than what would look like it would just
be a single outer ring there's like a
second ring which was a little more
mysterious about why that was there so
earlier we saw a set of people all
dressed in robes gathered at Stonehenge
and then they started walking around it
and you got to see how big the stones
are compared to a human being they're
like four or five times their height
were they Druids I don't know
for the longest time it was suspected
that The Druids were responsible for
Stonehenge but the earliest we can date
The Druids is thousands of years later
than the dating of the stones themselves
so
maybe The Druids used it
performed rituals around it but they're
not the ones who built it and that Still
Remains to be resolved in a way that we
can all agree as an astrophysicist as a
scientist to me that's an observatory in
addition to whatever else civilizations
might have used it for
Stonehenge
his name is Ty hi how he did we found
him yesterday to drive all of us out
here
last night and Ty you're telling me that
you heard or read or saw that Stonehenge
was a portal through space-time
Continuum
okay it's absolutely that's what you
heard but it's not absolutely that it's
true it's true that you heard it okay
okay we agree yeah okay all right well
you know I was told that that was that
was a portal and that's been broken down
because they don't want any other people
to go through it and when would as a
portal through space and time and who
who built the portal uh the aliens
aliens yeah okay okay wouldn't you think
they'd have materials more sophisticated
than rocks yes there are rocks yeah but
so the wood aliens they might be special
rocks
and they're in such a formation that
means that the formation is what does it
absolutely absolutely I like hearing
what people think okay so so that's how
the aliens would get from Earth to
somewhere else absolutely okay do you
think the only the aliens built that
yes okay that's why they're uh they're
different portals all over
the world and I and that's just one of
them
yeah okay how come we haven't seen this
lately
you might have seen him area 51. I'm not
authorized to comment on area
[Laughter]
[Music]
so it's day two now we're gonna attend
this sustainability conference for space
that's a new term space sustainability
we actually have an episode on that you
can dig it out of the archives so we're
attending that conference and we're
going to do a live Star Talk that's
going to be fun and it's at the Museum
of Science here in London
foreign
if you look at the total amount of money
spent in space today government
Investments is vanishingly small how
much what's being spent in space well
depends how you count it in space it
includes Commerce enabled by GPS
satellites yes the government launched
GPS satellites but now we have like uber
and you know you can get a car you can
find someone to mate with with Tinder
right or grinder using satellite
technology
I always think that the people who
invented this technology have any clue
how inventive people would invoke these
capabilities the point is all of that is
part of the space economy it would not
exist without it
welcome to StarTalk everyone this is
StarTalk devoted to space sustainability
first I got to bring in my co-host which
is part of the DNA of StarTalk a
professional stand-up comedian Matt come
on up Matt Matt winning yeah yeah come
on you have a seat we've got
Jenna Tawana Jenna come on up hello
so Jen is an airspace engineer and
you're also a head of Business
Development for ispace not head yet oh
not head yet okay and we also have
Danielle Wood an aerospace engineer from
MIT yes
excellent
everyone will look back on the several
hundred people in this conference and
say oh my gosh I wish I was at that
Gathering because that's where the rules
were set for how we now conduct business
in the future
thank you for sharing us your comments
and thank you all and to thank our
panelists thank you more but come on up
here
take us out
whoa wait let's do that for the camera
you ready go studying bioengineering the
calculator upstairs back ends
you're on a abbreviation basis I'm a
mechange okay
and you're bioengineering yeah I love
that so you're going to fix everything
[Laughter]
okay
and we all got that thing oh we got more
behind you here oh hello everybody
don't leave after physics
allow me to say that there is no
understanding of biology without
chemistry and there is no understanding
of chemistry without physics
it is foundational in this universe so
is physics the grandfather
or the grandmother grandmother
fathers can't birth anything okay get
you get your gender what would you get
with get with the program here all right
I shouldn't be the one to have to drag
you kicking and screaming into the 21st
century by the way my generation [ __ ]
up the world so you got to fix it okay
[Laughter]
okay we did something we brought you the
personal computer and my people did that
but then we didn't we weren't really
thinking about sustainability the future
multiculturalism there was a lot missing
from our portfolio and that is Center in
how you guys live today and think
it's second nature
so the fact that it's second nature
that's in a way we just discussed it in
this conference that may be your
superpower going forward
all right guys I gotta run okay thank
you
it still comes to an end star talks
Journey
encounter with London so there you have
it this is what we do
and you know why we do it try to bring
the universe Down to Earth for whoever
will watch this is Neil deGrasse Tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist keep
looking up